Kevin Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
what you can do to attract things into
your life faster enjoy
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations is like planting a seed in
the ground it's not necessarily true at
the moment but it is something you want
to have be true so you put the seed in
and you you you plant a seed and you
expect it to grow
when you maybe plant three seeds just in
case you expect them to grow and you
don't wait for two days and then dig in
the earth and say what's happening
what's happening you expect that thing
to grow because you know there's a law
and a process and the seed will grow if
it is in the right soil and it has the
right amount of moisture
looking at really a habit and doing it
every day doing something every morning
when you wake up that's a really good
time and another good time is when you
go to sleep at night and and gratitude
works a lot of just being grateful for
everything the more I always say the
universe loves gratitude the more you're
grateful for what the good is in your
life the more good you get to be
grateful about and it's like you know
somebody gives you a present and or
gives me a present I say oh my God I
hate that color and it doesn't fit and
you know that person will never give me
another present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you I really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude rule number two
is have a positive money mindset with
Marissa pier and Jack Kenfield the final
thing I love about your 64 principles
was the positive money mindset because I
see send me with the money blocks I mean
we know because 70 of the lottery
winners go dead bankrupt in three years
because of what you were just saying
before they don't have that mindset Tom
Jones said you know when I made it I had
to go to couldn't go to the pub if I
went to the pub in my Village and got
out my wallet there you go showing off
making us all feel bad if I didn't get
it out they go what's wrong with you Tom
you're a millionaire you can't even buy
us a drink anymore it's like I couldn't
win because he left his comfort zone in
many many lottery winners say well
I didn't know who I was I moved people
didn't like me if I stayed in the same
place I went you shouldn't be in this
Council house now you know you should
move it's not right and it it's getting
out of your comfort zone and I always
think the lottery winner figures are
phenomenal I mean I've worked with so
many lottery winners who went broke I've
worked with rock stars who are earning
20 million dollars a year for five years
it's not a long career and have no money
at the end so I'd love you to finish
with I mean I could talk to you forever
but I value your time
why is it so important to develop a
positive money mindset and how
how does our audience do that as far as
your um the positive money mindset goes
again it's a mindset it's a set of
thoughts and beliefs and so those
thoughts and beliefs were inculcated
either by your parents by the culture
you know money's evil easier for a camel
to go through the eye of a needle than a
rich man to get into heaven money
corrupts absolutely you know all that
kind of stuff that we hear growing up
the truth is it's not money doesn't
corrupt you the lust after money
corrupts you people don't even quote the
Bible correctly but the point is that we
can learn to be comfortable with money
and what I would encourage you to do is
to start examining your thoughts you do
that when you work with people you've
quoted lots of negative thoughts that
people bring up and then look at what is
the opposite thought you know and then
create an affirmation and write it down
and then repeat that affirmation over
and over and over and over like you can
basically do a couple of things negative
money beliefs can be tapped out using
EFT tapping you just tap on this belief
and you can tap that out literally you
can disappear a belief in like five to
ten minutes I've done that hundreds of
times with people you can go back to
Childhood uh I remember a woman who is
basically you talked about someone like
this you know we were very poor
therefore you know money doesn't grow on
trees and you can't we can't afford this
who do you think you are don't you care
about the rest of the family you're so
greedy all that kind of stuff that she
grew up with but when she went back and
saw that was just her parents living in
fear and that she was now 35 years old
the economy was different all that was
available she had new skills she could
use and she was able to say okay I can
have a new belief now now once you have
that new belief you can also put that in
by tapping on while you say the new
belief you know I have enough money to
do anything I want I have enough money
to do anything I want whatever it might
be and you get comfortable with that
belief you can have it on a card in my
wallet which I don't have because I
haven't used my wallet in two months
because I've only left my house once I
don't have it on my apartment personal
to him but where my driver's license
shows I have a affirmation for my goal
so every time I take my wallet out to
use a credit card I see this affirmation
for my goal
um another thing that my mentor W
Clement Stone taught me he was a good
friend in Napoleon Hill who wrote Think
and Grow Rich is always carry a hundred
dollar bill now when I learned that I
was not making that much money I was
probably making eighteen thousand
dollars a year as a school teacher in
Chicago and to carry a hundred dollar
bill around was like you know that was a
big chunk of money and he said every
time you pull out your money you're
going to see a hundred dollar bill and
you're gonna wow I'm rich so just
literally starting to act like that
another thing that people think they
have to do they think they have to be
rich to be generous
you can give away a small percentage of
your income you know one percent two
percent whatever you don't have to be
wealthy to tithe and once again you have
to do ten percent I do but you don't
have to but the point being if you tip
maybe go to an extra dollar and it makes
you feel a little wealthy that you were
able to do that there was a nice
generous thing you did and what I find
is the more I give away the more that
comes back to me uh I have about a
hundred trainers I've trained in India
to teach my work and I was just over
there in February and they had a little
reception for me and one of the guys who
is in charge of all these people over
there said to me he's now requiring
everyone there to do two free days of
training a month for the homeless for
women's shelters for sex trafficking of
shelters for people in prison for
schools Etc and he said every one of the
people who's actually doing it their
income's going up they're actually
charting this the more people give away
free time a couple times you don't want
to only be codependent give away all
your time that's also a problem but if
you give away a couple days a month to
charity to philanthropy to you know a
non-profit organization whatever what
happens is it comes back multiplied and
so the sense that I have in order to
give something I have to believe I have
enough and so it goes back to your I'm
not enough idea there's not enough time
not enough money whatever
um the truth is we all have the same
amount of seconds and minutes every day
and there's enough money I love the
quote from the Maharashtra the Mahesh
what the hell is he called Maharishi
Yogi and he was going to buy this school
it was a university was for sale in Iowa
and they've turned it into their
training center now and his students
said
but Maharishi where's the money going to
come from and he said from wherever it
is now
yeah I love it rule number three is feel
the future with Joe dispenza the person
who's living in lack is usually unworthy
is usually insecure is usually in their
past they're usually frustrated they're
usually impatient they're usually
resentful because nothing's changing out
there because it's taking too long well
that's everything takes a lot of time we
do matter to matter right
so then if you teach them okay
we know all about that we know the story
behind that we know what your parents
told you about money all that other
don't worry about it don't worry about
it
but now let's do something that would be
really cool let's let's write down the
feelings of how you would feel
if that future happened and you're going
to have to feel that feeling
before it occurs
so now
okay what is an abundant person feel
pretty much free a lot of freedom peace
excited joyful uh I'm in love with life
grateful to be alive abundant okay now
let's practice feeling those turns out
when you're feeling those other emotions
like resentment and impatience and
frustration
you're stepping on the gas pedal I'm
just turning on the sympathetic nervous
system and you're stepping on the brake
with the same time at the same time
which is you're angry you're frustrated
but the fight-or-flight nervous system
says run fight or hide and you're
sitting in a zoom meeting and you're
your neck is pulsating is because the
heart is beating against the closed
system right you're not you're not using
it in an Adaptive way so your heart
starts firing out of order it starts
firing incoherently and incoherent waves
cancel each other out it's called
destructive interference and then we
stop trusting our future energy leaves
the heart energy leaves the brain energy
leaves the heart
he can't get in touch with the feeling
of your future because in survival which
those are hormones of stress all those
emotions and survival is not a time to
create right it's time to run fight and
hide okay so we gotta lay down the very
thing we used our whole life to get what
we want the habit of doing it that way
for something greater to occur also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is takes
spiritually aligned action with Gabby
Bernstein what I teach in the book is
this method called the spiritually
aligned action method and it's a very
valuable method for the pushers out
there in the house okay
big one so when I was in my early my
late 20s I had been
I'd been teaching and speaking publicly
all throughout New York City for about
three years and at that time I'd also
got my first book deal my book was going
to come out in December of that year so
it was 20 2008 2009 I don't remember
it's been a while and I was
preparing for this book and I was
thinking about how I felt really deeply
called to bring this message to a new
audience of seekers a younger audience a
newer audience and now it's not that
crowd anymore specifically it's much
broader but at the time that was where I
was 28 years old I was I'm turning 40 in
two weeks people can you freaking
believe it
today somebody reminded me that and I
was like what
I'm farting okay
I've been doing this a long time okay so
I was 28 years old and this was all
coming to be in my life and I was
starting to see this trend and this new
Zeitgeist of young women trading in
their party for their for their
meditation and I was really at the
Forefront of that and I was was really
wanting to share that story in a bigger
way and I wanted it to be
having an impact and I wanted to find
people particularly in a place where
they may not have been looking for it
and so around that time
I saw this article on the Sunday style
section of the New York Times it was a
big big feature placement on the cover
of the style section
and I
noticed it was about my friends it was
about a bunch of my friends that were
food bloggers at the time and the
article came out and it blew their
careers up it got their messages out
into major ways they've gone on to have
massive businesses and great careers and
I was looking at that beautiful article
about these young food bloggers and I
saw what an impact it made on their
movement that they were creating and I
ripped that Masthead off the newspaper
and I put it on my vision board and I
was like that's what I want
and there was only one reporter at the
New York Times that I knew because
formerly my career was in PR so I knew
this guy and he was in my Rolodex no
joke Rolodex
and so I
spun through my Rolodex
and I found Alan salkin
as I call this guy Alan
and I'm cold calling he picks up the
phone he goes hello
hi Alan it's Gabby Bernstein we met a
year ago in SoHo at a dinner what do you
want
I have an interesting pitch for you I'll
make it really fast it's all the girls
that used to want to be like Carrie
Bradshaw now want to be like Wayne Dyer
and Marianne Williamson
and he said interesting
I'll get back to you
I hung up that phone and I was like I
got an interesting yes
that's major he's interested so the
thing I want to point out is that I
picked up that call with a lot of
conviction desire service love
confidence and excitement
and then I got the interesting and I
didn't think that was a good idea to
push that interesting I felt like it
would be nice to just let that
interesting unfold
so months went by and I let the
interesting unfold and he would send me
a few emails and he would message me at
times and say let's tell me a little bit
more about other people that are doing
this and how is this a trend and what's
happening and the months kept going by
and by and by and then about a month
before my book came out
I get a call from Alan
it's Alan
the New York Times is picking up your
story I'll see you at your apartment
next week we're going to videotape and
we're going to take photos and I'm going
to do an interview with you and I'll see
you there bye
my story was happening it was happening
it was happening so I was so pumped so
Alan came over that Monday night and he
watched me as I coached my group
coaching workshop and he sat on they
took photos and he was just a fly on the
wall taking notes
then when that was over they everybody
left the photographer left the students
left and I was left in my apartment with
Alan doing the interview
at the end of the interview Alan walks
over to my vision board
and he looks at the bottom right hand
corner
and he says
what's that pointing at the New York
Times Masthead
I said well you know Alan I've been
manifesting this article on this story
for a really long time about a year and
a half ago I saw this story about these
food bloggers and the style section and
I just knew that that was what I wanted
to manifest and he looked at me in total
shock and he said
I wrote that story
so yes this is a story of synchronicity
of course
but more important it's a story of how I
took spiritually aligned action to
manifest and co-create a desire that
really put me on the map rule number
five is Manifest your dreams with Dr
Tara sword Bieber once I discovered
neuroplasticity I thought I wish I'd
known about this when I was 18. really
you know it's literally life-changing I
think I was naturally manifesting from
about the age of 18 anyway but I didn't
understand the science behind it once
you understand that you can literally
change your brain at any stage any age
any mindset
that's like
it's life-changing isn't it and and I
feel that you know one of the things we
were sort of chatting about earlier is
that just because I'm a scientist and an
MD it doesn't mean that in my real life
it's easy for me to just Channel
neuroplasticity it's still it's still
hard you know I've been through a
divorce I've been through grief I've
been through career change
and
those Hard Times taught me resilience
and neuroplasticity
but the hard times were almost the
opportunity I didn't want to go through
those things I don't want you know our
listeners to go through hard times yeah
pain but
you can take that as an opportunity and
I think if you really understand
neuroplasticity then you can make the
worst times in your life the start of
the best time in your life and that's
what I love about neuroplasticity that
it's that ability to change to grow to
regulate your emotions which I know
you're really into and and build
resilience I mean an example of
neuroplasticity that I would share with
with you with our listeners is
gratitude lists
so for years in my journaling I would
write 10 things I'm grateful for every
day
and they were always external things
friends family travel you know
um Financial Freedom whatever and I
literally just got bored of writing the
same things so I thought okay what what
else could I write so I started writing
things like my creativity my
vulnerability my resilience internal
things
and that was a real game changer really
what happened when you started doing
that it made me think that whatever life
throws at me I've got the tools and
resources within me to deal with it
um and and I didn't always have you know
in my 20s
I wouldn't say I was very emotionally
regulated
but
learning that
whatever happens the sort of
the pendulum swing for your emotions the
higher it goes the lower it goes as well
and and bringing that to like parameters
that you're comfortable with is
that gives you sort of autonomy and
agency in life sure
um and and again that's the thing I love
about neuroplasticity and rule number
six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is feel good with
Ronda Brown how do I feel from this how
do I feel and act as if I don't have
money problems when I can't pay my bills
okay well you're talking to somebody
you're talking to somebody that had the
exact same problem I was in so much debt
making the secret I mortgage my home I
took overdrafts on my company I maxed
out my credit cards to the Limit and
um and so
I know what it's like so first of all
when you can't pay your bills one of the
things that I did with my bills is I
knew I needed to feel good right and
it's very hard when you can't pay your
bills to feel good because you get a pit
in your stomach you can't pay them and
you just or you can't sleep and all of
those thoughts come so the first thing
to do is do whatever you need to do
whether it's gratitude listen to your
favorite song that you want to dance to
or just do something that makes you feel
really really really good and while you
were feeling really good open up your
bills this is what I used to do I didn't
open them up when I felt bad because I
knew if I did that I would attract more
bills so I opened them up when I felt
really good then I pretended
that every one of those bills was a
check for me
and I would tally up the bills as though
there are all checks and then I would
get all excited that I just received all
of this money
um in the mail and uh and that's what I
would do and you know then I would pay a
little bit off a bill when I could pay
it off but then when I did pay something
off the Bill here's the other something
else that I did and you will see that
all of this is about
stopping resistance and it's about
feeling good so the other thing that I
did was um now I've forgotten I've said
that I forgot what I did I'll come back
I'll come back to that
um also I did affirmations every day
with every footstep the secret to the
money app secret to money app I would
write checks to myself I would do all
kinds of things they're all the
practices that I would do in in the
money at
um so I would you know really highly
recommend that but other than that
affirmations are so great to do just to
do affirmations and it helps to kind of
convince you that you have some more
money
um and so the most important thing is to
feel good you know just feel good about
about opening up the bills and and so
you've got to get yourself feeling good
and I know what it's like you know I it
took a lot for me to do it but I I did
it I was absolutely determined oh yes he
was the other thing that I was going to
tell you when you're paying a bill
uh I would pay I would pay it and so
what I would do is I would imagine
all of the people that work in that
company and that the money that I'm
paying is going to help them buy food
for their family
pay for fuel for that car it's going to
help pay their mortgage it's going to
help buy clothes and then so I would
think of everybody in the company then I
would think about all of the other
companies that uh that connect to that
company so I think if the truck drivers
how this money that I'm paying to this
company ultimately is going to help the
truck drivers who deliver Goods to to
this company and it's going to help
their families and so I would just keep
thinking about all of these people that
my money that I'm paying is going to
help
and oh my God is it gosh it just did
wonders it really did wonders
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is law of
gravity anything heavier than Earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work well I use a
diagram to explain the mind now let this
circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now I want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
and here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it the body does not stop
moving if you go to a funeral parlor and
pick up the remains and look at it you
will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the Dust
you move into your body and you will
move up and it's how you use your mind
that's going to dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here and that separates the conscious
mind from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed when you're a little baby
this is the way it was or just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm now a
paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you were
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for Generations now I'm going
to say that the Paradigm is X-Type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think and you can
think anything you want to think
and as you think you build ideas there's
a power that's flowing into your
Consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think
X-Type thoughts therefore you're going
to be in an X-Type vibration
and that will produce X-Type results now
it's the results you want to change and
to change the results you're going to
have to change what you attract you see
the thoughts that you think control the
vibration that you're in vibration is
nothing but an idea it's a law of the
universe everything vibrates nothing
rests we live in an ocean of motion and
it's the thoughts that you're thinking
that you impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the vibration the
body's in and that dictates how you act
but it also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's a
infinite number of frequencies but you
and I operate on the frequency just like
a radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned into the vibration you're in now
it's the Paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change our thinking but that
doesn't do anything you've got to change
the paradigm and if you don't change the
Paradigm nothing happens now talking
about paradigms is another subject we'll
do that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the Paradigm that's
causing the problem you can think a Y
type thought which is totally different
than the X-Type conditioning it isn't
going to go anywhere because when you go
to get emotionally involved and this is
the emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
type done the Paradigm will kick it out
you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the Paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration you're in is going to dictate
what you attract
people that are in a poverty
Consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in and your
whole world changes listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what I tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but I did
exactly what he said and you know
something my income went from 4 000 to
175 000 in a year and then I took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what I'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here and another
lesson I'm going to show you how to
change the Paradigm when you change the
Paradigm the change in results is
automatic you know why you start to
attract something then something
different and what we want to do is
program in positive information and
eliminate the negative I'm going to show
you how to do that
a law of attraction
you attract according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy do you know if you put
your body in front of an infrared
television camera in a completely dark
room your whole being would be nothing
but a glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good we're in a negative vibration
you want to feel good move into a
positive vibration stop and think of
what you're grateful for
but understand this you will never
attract to you wealth happiness health
until you get the Paradigm get you on
that frequency your personality
literally ad is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called a mood so you say Ed what's wrong
with you I'm in a mood why are you in a
mood well this thing happened to me five
days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electro magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
heart of yours to bloom once they're
able to feel even the smallest measure
of gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life when we talk about
or think about the law of attraction
before we even consider that law and
several other corollary laws
when we talk about everything is energy
what does that really mean
right like what does that really mean
and when you think about you know we use
telescopes to look into outer space into
the cosmos and we use microscopes to
look deeper into material things until
it all disappears anyway right we can
see electrons and protons and muons and
quarks and leptons the Very fundamental
building blocks of nature of our body of
plants of the ocean of everything in the
known Cosmos and it appears
that everything is vibrating if you were
to look through these electron
microscopes you know deep into a plant
or even your hand although it appears to
be solid
um we see vibrating packets of this
thing we call Energy vibrating packets
of something called quanta right and so
if everything is vibrating
then is it possible and this is a
dialogue right is it possible that when
you and I have a thought
a positive one a negative one a thought
about something we want or something we
don't want right so it's a thought a
spark of electrochemical activity in the
brain of thought we say you know I want
this I don't want that is it possible
let's just have a little dialogue here
is it possible that since that thought
is a burst of electrical activity and
also releases a chemical that correlates
with that thought is it possible
that the electrochemical activity is
vibrating
oscillating moving whatever you want to
call it at a certain frequency
that resonates or repels with certain
things in the physical world is it
possible if everything is energy
um
how do you get into resonance with what
it is you want to you know attract how
do you get mentally physically
emotionally spiritually in resonance
with the stuff that you want instead of
what you don't want here's one of the
biggest challenges
our brains are wired for safety first
emotional safety physical safety
Financial safety first and so in order
to protect ourselves our brain actually
has to think about where is their danger
like where could I get hurt and in
thinking about where you can get hurt is
it possible that sometimes we're in a
temporary or permanent state of fear and
if we're in a permanent or temporary
state of fear is it possible that that
state of fear or uncertainty or
self-doubt is actually attracting
resonating with the stuff that we don't
want
one of the keys to applying the law of
resonance
is getting your mindset right the brain
right focused on what it is that you
want
getting your heart
right the emotions aligned as well so
it's head and heart aligned also with
what it is you want to resonate with
and then there's another piece to it
that not a lot of people think about or
talk about and that's the gut
right the brain gut access is in
communication with each other at all
times and there's a lot of research
around you've got to really follow your
instincts right your intuition your
instinctual feeling about stuff so you
got to get the head the heart and the
gut aligned and that is really the
winning combination to be in a state of
resonance everyone has unresolved areas
where they are out of alignment due to
their upbringing their belief systems
from childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted so some people might be
Health some people might be sex some
people it might be money some people it
might be their worth some people might
be all of the above whatever we've all
got it we've all got an area or many
where we are misaligned with the feeling
of love and abundance and and Grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are doing anything wrong
it's that you are your awareness of it
is actually major okay so the undoing of
the lack mentality is a journey of
clearing the belief systems from a
experiential time in your life right
that happens once again through books
like the universe has your back so
fantastic that you're doing that
transform fear to Faith excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural Pathways from the
experiences that we've had as children
particularly young childhood experiences
but the good news is thanks to
neuroplasticity our brain actually can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our PTSD can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new Behavior so one thing that you can
do simply In This Moment is to notice
when you are in that lack mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method I've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes I could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy whichever one I hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but what you can do
for yourself you're here for self-help
you're here for Gabby to tell me how I
can serve myself you can be in the
proactive development of new thought
patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack Story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel step two forgive
yourself for having the thought it's
very simple up there is my childhood
story there's my parents lack story
again up there it is again all right I
forgive myself it just showed up again
because that forgiveness will dissolve
that guilt and tension and fear that
you're manifesting it all that crap
right
third step choose the next best feeling
thought choose the thought of you know
what I just forgave myself for that
thought so I'm dissolving it in this
moment I actually am listening to the
universe has your back and it's so
supportive then I can actually go and
listen to Super tractor so you can go
from thought to thought to thought to
reach for the next best feeling thought
so your willingness to face this lack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you right and
especially if you're feeling afraid that
you're manifesting things because you're
having the thoughts then just forgive
the thoughts because or forgive yourself
for having the thought because the
moment that you say oh I forgive myself
for that thought or I forgive that
thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized I am not that
thought it's just a thought that I keep
thinking I am not that belief it's just
a thought that I keep thinking becoming
a monk was my biggest dream growing up
from that time period that I made the
monk 18 which we spoke about the last
time I was here and so that became like
my identity from 18 to 22 and then 22 to
25 when I lived as a monk so it's like
that's been my identity for seven years
at least in my heart and my head and so
when you get to the end of a
self-awareness Journey which is actually
the beginning but you get to the end of
it because you're like oh I'm not a monk
anymore and I'm sure you've gone through
similar things like oh I'm not a CEO
anymore of this right of a business that
does this or someone else may go through
I'm not married anymore
I'm now divorced I am now not single
anymore or I'm not alone I've got kids
right it's like we all go through these
identity transitions in our life and to
me going from being among to not being a
monk was the hardest transition that I'd
been through at that time
and the question that I'm having is
I'm having Reflections on who I truly am
and what my skills are what my strengths
are what my passion is what my
compassion is and I'm saying I want to
share all of this in like a cool way
through entertainment and I love movies
and that's where the book's full of like
pop culture references and it's it's a
it's it's who I am and what I love about
myself
and then I'm going but this doesn't
align with what monk life is meant to be
in a sacred way
and that is like looking in the mirror
and going oh like I'm not comfortable
with that so when I share that with my
teacher and we're having this discussion
here's his advice and I think that's the
part that you're referring to he says to
me that
there's
students that come to University
and then they become professors and
there are students that come to the
university and then they go out and
become entrepreneurs or go out and work
and he says which do you think are
better
I'm like I mean neither really like I
can't really choose what makes someone
better and he was just like that's the
point you you came here
some people stay at the monastery and go
on to become senior monks and teachers
and some people will go out and do what
they do outside and he goes but then
either is better and it was the simplest
advice it's one of those pieces of
advice that it's all about the person
that says it and not necessarily what
you're hearing but for me it just
clarified the Judgment I had
the attachment I had
that I could only be happy and
purposeful in this way and that's really
what we're all struggling with that
currently we all have a projector screen
up here that goes this is what life's
meant to look like for it to be happy
and then down here we have the reality
version of what life actually looks like
and we go oh no they don't match that
doesn't match that's not working that
means I'm going on the wrong direction
the funny thing is the version you have
doesn't exist at all it's just an
imagination it's it's virtual reality
and the reality that you're experiencing
could actually be getting you closer to
that goal than you even think but you
just don't want to go down that path
because it doesn't look like the one you
imagine and that's where I was at I was
having to go down a path that I didn't
imagine looked like success
but then the question is well what does
success look like then and it definitely
doesn't look like the version in your
head
so to me I started to realize and I
genuinely believe this
and your affirmation is very useful to
me the three years of my life living is
a monk well like being at monk school
and the last seven years have been the
exam
and everything in this book is stuff
that I've tried and tested in the last
seven years I learned it among school
but I tested it in in reality and I'm
only sharing what in the last seven
years has perfectly worked for me to
feel like I'm exactly where I need to be
doesn't mean I don't have off days that
doesn't mean that I'm happy all the time
it doesn't mean that I don't get angry
it doesn't mean that I don't get upset
but I'm going in the direction that I
want to be going in I used to struggle a
lot with manifesting just the idea of it
I would watch videos on it and I didn't
understand what they were saying I
didn't I just didn't understand it uh
with this manifest in a lot of
attractions like what are they saying I
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind and watch again it's like I don't
get it I don't understand I don't I
don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on the couch and think about money
coming into your wallet or whatever it
was that you're trying to manifest you
got to go do something that in law of
attraction you know action is at the end
of Attraction like you got to go off and
do the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain playing it from a
different perspective and and maybe
it'll help at least this is what's
helped me the first thing that I
realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
are there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you're looking
at the cuddle of the sky you're looking
at the house you look at the what
material that might be you're not
looking at anything again it's too
blurry you're still looking at my face
you're looking at my car you're looking
at the color of the headrest you're
looking at my outfit like what are you
paying attention to most things you're
ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often why that's your reticular
activating system basically saying I
want to pay attention to those things so
that car was still around right I mean I
I got this car we've got a Porsche and
now I see Porsches more often those
Porsches still existed they were they
were already there I just didn't notice
them before and now I notice them
because I have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with
and as soon as I came up with an idea I
was like oh you can't do that or I had
to have the perfect Plan before I would
ever take any kind of action on it and
you know just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait till
you have the perfect plan by the time
you start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust that it's already and then go
do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but I just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times that has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one particular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car uh when you
buy your new car you see that car
everywhere and then number two is trust
a good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
uh that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and just 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something I
would tell other people you know like oh
yeah yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because because it I haven't spoken at a
stadium that big but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
David but look I've got I've got a belly
here I've got a you know whatever I'm
I'm I am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like manifestation law
of attraction was way out there stuff
that that I judged and that I didn't
understand and that didn't make any
sense like just go off and take action
guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to
manifest success into your life check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there what the heck is
manifesting Mel Robbins well let me tell
you what manifesting isn't okay
manifesting is not thinking thoughts and
then hoping that they come true thoughts
become things only when your thoughts
inspire you to take the actions